[Music]  in times of old the world was full of  wonder and magic but times change warner  mom hey birthday boy by the laws of your  I must dub thee a man today kneel before  me that's okay I have a gift from your  dad  Jesus said to give you this when you  were both over sixteen no it's a wizard  step dad was a wizard what your dad was  an accountant  this spell brings him back for one whole  day dad will be back what act like back  to life that's not possible it is with  this I'm gonna meet dad  [Music]  ah he's just legs I definitely remember  dad having a top part what did I do  hi we only have 24 hours to bring the  rest of him back until then hey Dad you  look just like I remember  a problem Shane  you see you come to the right  oh we might be out of gas but it says we  have a full tank that doesn't work  growth spell we grow the can and then  the gas inside will grow with it  the can is huge and the fan is huge and  your Oh No  [Music]